سوءا يوما تلو الاخر وذلك مع
تراكم السفن في مضيق البوسفور.
القضية الفلسطينية. وزير
الخارجية التركي مولود شاووش
مواطنيها واعتماد النظام العالمي
في حساب الاعمار. وهذا التعديل
لتعلنها السلطة البحرية التركية
في بيان بلادنا ليست ملزمة
العام بينهم اكثر من سبعمائة
وخمسين طفلا. روسيا قد تنتقل
تحرير عفرين في منطقة غصن
الزيتون. هناك جرا بوتين اتصالا
المئة من المنتجات بعد ارتفاع
التجارة البينية غير النفطية مئة
قطر. عفيه وعفيتين. هكذا كان
يقول لنا والدي واليوم نهديها
بانشاء امنية بعمق ثلاثين كيلو
مترا في شمال سوريا. وعلى خط
واربعة عشر في المائة في تسعة
اشهر. فلتنفض غبار قبرك يا زايد
الفوز الجميل. الامارات والكيان
الاسرائيلي يصادقان على اتفاقية
صدام حسين تهنئ منتخب المغرب
بانجازه التاريخي في مونديال
المياه التركية لعدم حصولها على
خطابات تأمين وسط استياء غربي
شراكة اقتصادية شاملة لالغاء او
خفض الرسوم على ستة وتسعين في
لفرحة النساء. تطبق نظرية بوتين.
العثمانيون يمشون وفق نظرية الدب
نادي الاسير الفلسطيني. اسرائيل
اعتقلت نحو ستة فلسطيني منذ مطلع
حربهم العلنية. هنا تواصل انقرة
عملياتها في الشمال السوري.
المتحدة. ومن الحرب النفطية ضد
مجاعة الطاقة الاوروبية يعود الى
لمواجهة مباشرة مع الغرب وكل
الطرق تؤدي الى المواجهة. فهل
هاتفيا مع اردوجان لتهدئة الوضع.
لكن الرئيس التركي يؤكد تمسكه
العمال الكردستاني. وقالت انه
كان يتولى قيادة ما تسمى قوات
الدفاع التركية تعلن مقتل من
وصفته بانه احد ارهابيي حزب
نووي في عام الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين. وعلى طريقة والدها رغد
الكورية. حيث اقرت كوريا
الجنوبية تعديل قانون حساب اعمار
بمراقبة قرارات العقوبات الصادرة
عن دول ومنظمات دولية اخرى
شمال البلاد ليكونا عبرة
لغيرهما. وعندما نطلق عليه عبارة
الروسي مع الاوروبيين. حيث تواصل
انقرة منع ناقلات النفط من دخول
لكم ايها الاحبة عفيا وعفيتين.
يا شعب المغرب العزيز علينا هذا
سيجعل الكوريين اصغر بعام او
عامين مما هو في وثائقهم. فيا
لحل ازمة ناقلات النفط العالقة
في البحر الاسود والتي تزداد
العرفة البلغارية العمياء التي
قيل انها توقعت حرب اوكران
كوريا الشمالية كل ما يخص جارتها
الجنوبية ممنوع في البلاد واي
الجزائر ليست معكم في خط التطبيع
يا اوغلو. الاحداث والتطورات.
وجائحة كورونا تظهر توقعات جديدة
بينها تغير مدار الارض وانفجار
لا ننشر دون مصادر. ومن الشمال
الى الجنوب في شبه الجزيرة
جنوبية ليتم اطلاق النار عليهما
امام السكان المحليين في مدينة
اوغلو تركيا والجزائر على خط
واحد بالنسبة لفلسطين. ولكن
هكذا تبدو الامور. وذلك مع ترقب
لزيارة وفد امريكي رفيع المستوى
بينما تواصل الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية ضغوطاتها على تركيا
باستثناء قرارات العقوبات التي
يتخذها مجلس الامن التابع للامم
عشرة والاخر في السابعة عشرة
بتهمة توزيع ومشاهدة افلام كورية
اتجاه طي الخلافات وبدء صفحة
جديدة من العلاقات بين البلدين
مجنون يتضايق الاخر لذا سنضع لكم
رابط المصدر في اول تعليق. فنحن
الى السلم بعد كل تلك الحروب
الباردة? المحظور لدى كيم. في
معروفة. وها هو المجنون يعدم
مراهقين اثنين احدهما في السادسة
تداول لها يعتبر خيانة عظمى ومن
يخالف قوانين كم فعقوباته
الى الصين لبث الدفء على
العلاقات الثنائية. فهل يجنحون
الفادحة لقواته لكنه قال ان من
المهم ابقاء قنوات الاتصال
الطيارة ويمكنها اطلاق صواريخ
تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت. الصين
اوروبا تسعى عصفورين بحجر واحد
بتحديد سقف لاسعار النفط الروسي
واقامة دولة فلسطينية على حدود
عام الف وتسعمائة وسبعة وستين
يتعرض له الفلسطينيون. اذا
فلتعطني اذنك يا شي. اقترب اكثر.
تكررت القمم يا شي? لكن من جهة
اخرى واشنطن مع بكين تمضيان في
الرئيس الصيني يهاجم الاسلام
فوبيا ويدعو لوقف الظلم الذي
من روسيا سرا وذلك عبر دول وسيطة
للالتفاف على العقوبات الغربية
بالامم المتحدة. جاء هذا بعد قمة
واحدة فقط مع العرب. فكيف لو
الالماني من خلال بلجيكا بحسب
قناة الالمانية. وبين هذا وذاك
تسليح روسيا. مشيرا الى انه لم
ير اي مؤشرات على ان موسكو ستدخل
المفروضة على موسكو الغاز الروسي
مستمر في التدفق الى المستهلك
الجديد والتي تستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي حيث يمكنها التخفي
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقية ومنح
الفلسطينيين العضوية الكاملة
المانيا ودول اخرى في الاتحاد
الاوروبي الغاز الطبيعي المسال
اريد ان اخبرك سرا. وماذا عن
مسلمي الايجور? لن يسمعنا احد
في وجه اسرائيل. قمة العرب
والصين بدأت تؤتي ثمارها. فها هو
هل تنجح اوروبا في مساعيها? في
السياق ذاته نفى وزير الخارجية
بسرعة كبيرة ويتاح لها ايضا
استخدام اجهزة استشعار متطورة،
الهدف من المبادرة هو ضمان عدم
وقوع اي انقطاعات في امدادات
في مفاوضات بنوايا حسنة. ننتقل
الى حرب الخدع والحيل حيث تشتري
جيمس كليفلي ويقول لا يجب ان
تكون المفاوضات ستارا لاعادة
الالمان شولز مصرحا ان بوتين يصر
على مواصلة الحرب رغم الخسائر
واذا لزم الامر يمكن للمقاتلة
الجديدة الطيران دون تدخل من
مفتوحة مع بوتين للحديث معه
للخروج من الحرب التي تسبب بها.
لتخفيف الاعباء عن المواطنين
وارتفاع الاسعار في الاتحاد
مجددا الى طاولة الاتحاد
الاوروبي بسبب النفط الروسي
ومن حرب اوكرانيا الى حرب
الخلافات الاوروبية والتي تعود
في مصلحة الولايات المتحدة بحسب
صحيفة واشنطن الامريكية. اما في
بريطانيا واليابان تتحالف لتطوير
طائرة حربية مقاتلة من الجيل
لنكمل. وخلال كلمته في قمة
الرياضة دعم بكين حل الدولتين
الغاز بين الدول الثلاث الجارة.
ليخرج وزير الخارجية البريطاني
مبادرة انشاء اتحاد للغاز بين
وكازاخستان واوزباكستان واكد ان
الروسي سيرجي لافروف وجود اي
لعبة سياسية او جيوسياسية في
استهداف العصب الاوكراني الحساس
على امتداد خريطتها بضربات مركزة
في وقت يبدو انه الاصعب وهو فصل
الشتاء. هناك ايضا اعلنت الدفاع
الروسية استهداف رتل من المدرعات
الاوكرانية بغارات جوية مستشار
الاوروبي وكذلك الضغط على موسكو
اقتصاديا واضعافها. لكن برأيكم
جميعها ركزت على تدمير البنية
التحتية ليرد الاوكران بهجمات
العسكرية ليرد البيت الابيض ان
روسيا تعتزم رفع وتيرة عملياتها
روسيا تحشد قواتها في لوجانسك
بكثافة لتستعد لمهام مشيرة الى
المتطورة. ومضيفا ان عدو روسيا
ليست كييف فقط بل اوروبا وامريكا
ويقصد بذلك ان كانت حربا فهم
مستعدون حسب تعبيره. ليخرج لنا
المدينة وبشكل يومي حسب تعبيره.
نعم يا سادة فروسيا تواصل
اعلن الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي ان
مليونا ونصف المليون شخص في
للكهرباء. ليجدوا انفسهم في ظلام
حالك بلا تدفئة وبلا ماء حيث
القتالية في اوكرانيا صعيد
الصراع العسكري في اوكرانيا ليس
تحتاج للذكاء حتى يعلم العالم
انها ستندلع في اي لحظة بدأت
مفاجئة على فهل ترفع هذه الهجمات
من جوزية كييف لحشود موسكو
باردة لكن نارها توقد ببطء
ليستوي جمرها في احشاء رمادها.
هنا الكرملين يؤكد ذلك. وعلى
لسان ديمتري بيسكوف قائلا ان
يد في ذلك? وقوات انقرة تواصل
ضرباتها ابنة صدام حسين تهنئ
المغرب على طريق والدها الراحل
والامارات تدق مسمارا اخر في نعش
الروسي. لكن الروس يركزون قليلا
على اوكرانيا. وهى بضعة حشود
الامن الروسي. معلنا ان بلاده
تعمل على تكثيف انتاج الاسلحة
الشمالية واليابان ونيوزيلاندا
وغيرها من الدول بحسب الاعلام
ان القوات الروسية نفذت ستين
هجوما في خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة
ان روسيا تحتاج الى العيش وفقا
للظروف التي تفرضها هذه المرحلة.
هنا المعروف بصرامة تصريحاته.
ديمتري ميدفيديف نائب رئيس مجلس
وسط صقيع الشتاء فيواجه
الاوكرانيون انقطاعا شبه تام
اوديسا ومحيطها من الكهرباء بسبب
استهداف روسيا للبنية التحتية في
عسكرية تفزع كييف. حيث افادت
هيئة الاركان الاوكرانية بان
الشقيقة الفلسطينية. روسيا تتحضر
للحرب الكبرى. هذه الحرب لا
الاحتلال فيما امريكا تفتح صفحة
جديدة مع الصينيين فماذا سيكتبون
جديدة. وتركيا تقف حجر عثرة امام
وصول النفط لاوروبا. فهل لموسكو
العلاقة بين روسيا والغرب وصلت
الى مرحلة المواجهة. لافتا الى
فيها في الايام القادمة? المجنون
يستمر باعداماته الغريبة بحادثة
على رأس الاتحاد وتسريبات
استخباراتية تضع المانيا في موقف
صعب امام الاوروبيين والرئيس
الصيني يقف قضية الفلسطينية ضد
وسيول بشرية روسية عسكرية تسبب
الفزع للاوكران. فما الذي يجري
وعلاقتنا بالغرب وصلت لمرحلة
المواجهة. هكذا قالتا موسكو
سنترك مشاهدة كأس العالم لنشاهد
حربا لا تنطفئ نارها اذا اشتعلت?
الاتحاد الاوروبي يسعى لاصابة
عصفورين بحجر واحد ليسقط الحجر